here all the places you should travel in
2016
Normandy friends the Tour de France is
launching from Mont saint-michel and
there's a try annual impressionist
festival I'd go if I were you
Cuba American tourism to Cuba has
swelled since the loosening of travel
restrictions make plans now before it
gets too crowded Bavaria Germany they're
celebrating the 500th anniversary of an
old beer Purity law meaning them even
more festive Oktoberfest than usual
Botswana Botswana is celebrating 50
years of independence this year don't
just want to celebrate with them Great
Barrier Reef Australia the Australian
dollar is falling and the cold reef is
shrinking so it might be now or never
a Kyoto Japan after ten years of
construction you'll finally be able to
reach the northernmost island of Japan
by bullet train Rio de Janeiro the
Olympics this summer means the party in
Brazil will be more fire than ever
Greenland's the Northern Lights run on
an 11-year cycle they won't be this
bright again until 2024 by that time who
knows how much ice will be left National
Parks USA it's the hundredth anniversary
of the National Park Service do yourself
a service and go Maldives the islands
are the world's lowest lying nation and
sea level rise could make them
uninhabitable another one to see sooner
rather than later so where are you gonna
go in 2016